There's a lot to learn
with making
background transactions efficient,
but the good news
is that Android gives you
the SyncManager framework
that implements many
of these best practices.
You utilize that framework
by implementing a SyncAdapter.
The framework, originally introduced
in Android 2.0 Eclair
or Android API level 5,
allows Android applications
to leverage the same
basic framework that Google apps
use for efficient synchronization.
Ultimately, it's a
centralized place to put
all of the device data transfers
in one place.
So that they all be scheduled
intelligently by the OS.
In other words, that's one big cookie!
Android SyncManager handles
synchronization requests
using SyncAdapters.
The SyncManager batches
and time shifts these requests,
when possible, to allow
your data transfers
to be scheduled with transfers
from other apps,
all working towards the goal
of reducing the number of times
the system has
to switch on the radio.
If your device has less memory,
it will schedule fewer
simultaneous synchs.
The SyncManager also
takes care of things
like checking for network connectivity
before initiating transfers
and retrying downloads
when connectivity is dropped.
The synchronization framework
works with content providers
for two way synchronization
and leverages
the Android Account Manager to provide
synchronization services
that are tied to accounts.
Our application will do neither
of these things,
but we'll still have to deal
with some of the complexity
of these features.
This can make SyncAdapter
seem daunting at first.
What does the SyncManager do
to help you fetch
data from the network?
Does it schedule your network jobs
with other apps,
implement a syncrhonization protocol,
store account information,
or has logic to retry your request?
Select all of these that match.